[Musique]
il
et
mathis en faveur de la solution hydro
alcoolique selon la formule de l' oms
c'est une formule que pharmacien
français ont découvert y avait un mois
pour combattre les limites coronavirus
et cette formule
elle est très simple ces quatre produits
qu'ils sont
très sympa mélange entre hausses et de
l'alcool à 96 de l'éthanol de la
glycérine de l'oxygène et de mai
[Musique]
oui on a à peu près 7 9 puis je demande
à ce point capable de faire ce qu'on
fabrique à peine dix minutes par jour à
ses offres sont une famille dans l'it
europe par jour de demande n'est pas
capable de satisfaire le monde selon
vous satisfaire en priorité des pour
faire pharmaciens
santé photo les états
c'est tout aussi dépenses de lens
[Musique]
our soit ni masque ni dial et les
clients réclament donc on a reçu un mail
en urgence cette nuit comme qu'on
pouvait se faire livrer ici
donc voilà je suis venu avec ma petite
smart et je peux prendre que son litre
au lieu de prendre deux solides parce
que j'ai pas le plus grosses voitures
c'est surtout qu'on n'ait pas fourni ni
en masque je tire le béaba quoi le le
minimum requis et c'est vrai que les
gens ils comprennent pas moi même c'est
dommage de qui est plein de
contamination pour juste la base
[Musique]
[Rires]
en fait le site de m'organiser
10e comme matière première est donc cet
alcool de bush est très proche en fait
en termes de qualité de l'alcool
politique
il est en fait citer deux
bonnet cet alcool
aux pharmaciens pour eux-mêmes produire
des jeunes familles est en fait allé
plus loin se dire pourquoi on ferait pas
nous-mêmes président pour la sécurité
réunis on a largement
on a tout pour faire il y avait une
vraie envie de nos employés de le faire
[Rires]
[Musique]
non
ça revient